I'm just trying to use this platform to
help more I think this is really
important because not discussing like
you know because they're obviously there
is there is the halal Haram aspect of
him and whatnot and I talked about much
on my show before you're already
involved in this part right now you're
already involved in it and what I try to
do is motivate people just like you that
now you have you made a decision you're
an adult you're soundin adult you know
what you're doing okay you've wait
things out
you're you've now Wanda's belt okay yeah
but at the end of the day you know that
the Creator the heavens and earth does
he really is this gonna is this gonna
carry you tomorrow in the grave and all
the money that you make you making
millions now no but all that stuff we're
leaving it behind you're gonna take all
that tomorrow you start writing nice
cars and you know big homes is that
gonna go with you no it's a tomorrow you
know I try to motivate you know and I'm
sure your your you're also the your
brother-in-law he's one of my friends
Sheikh Omar right hold on stay mind I'm
sure you probably hear this a lot from
him but you know and others that now you
got you when people are given this
responsibilities platform what are you
gonna do with it now yeah I mean are you
gonna help make a difference are you
gonna help make a change
you found me while others you know they
get over overexcited with the platform
and they use it for their own benefit
but they don't give back yeah yeah yeah
I mean when I first won this you know it
for a whole four I mean I've been
fighting for this for two years and a
half like in in this promotion winning
every fight undefeated in that promotion
just to get reach this and especially
the last four month of training camp we
and that's all I was thinking about is
winning this but you know it felt good
the first day or two then now to me it's
just like you know metal with like
leather you know it's it's not really
worthless but the reason I carry it
around is because the hope it gives the
people I see like you know little kids
when they see a bell you know their eyes
glow and oh wow you know world champion
and I want to be a world champion and
and this the things that does to other
people you know I'm still like showing
it around to like little kids and doing
these little events and that's the
reason I do this you know like I said it
not something like it's not a hobby
right now for me it's a responsibility I
have a lot of people looking up watching
every move I make so if I do something
good or something bad
there's a lot of people watching so I
make sure it's always something good and
it's not something I'm doing because I
became a world champion it was always
there with me but like I said it's our
responsibility now because I'm on a
platform and there's a lot of eyes
watching to try to you know show the
image over the religion of just being
human as well like you know yeah it's
not always whole helping Muslims only
know non-muslims as well we do food
drives we do a lot of you know good
things just to people here in the USA
and it's just about also being human you
know good humans good Muslims and just
helping around that stay because I said
everyone has a message they're sure
they're saying someone else's message
copy caddy and passing another thing
negative setting netic negative trends
but setting good trends being good
examples and there's this powerful and
is different than the average layman
says it so when you have someone who you
mentioned your friend our brother Habib
when he mentioned in front of a huge
group of people then that obviously you
know the camera recorded and went out to
so many where he said he said stay
connected to God number one important
most important cross state connect when
together right
strong that's powerful right so now he
went on to say stay connected to prayer
he would always have to pray you always
have to stay humble and staying focused
and staying connected together he said
keep it humble right where what do you
see usually if someone wins a belt right
win some money then the pride kicks in
the arrogance right ego you've seen that
of course of course and